if you feel like a cinema outing or one
of these cold dark nights I recommend
you check out Armando Iannucci zni
release David Copperfield an adaptation
of the 1815 novel it is wonderful
warming funny and irresistible uplifting
and a big part of that comes from the
film's colorblind casting that's the
decision to cast without considering
skin color or ethnicity featuring deaf
Patel as the lead alongside a host of
other talented actors of color the
casting for David Copperfield has
produced a highly acclaimed film
honestly it's a relief and a few minutes
into the film you wonder why on earth it
took so long explaining his decision to
cast Patel is lead director Iannucci
said it just felt like why are we not
doing this
he hopes the film will change minds
within the industry color conscious
casting doesn't replace the need for a
spectrum of stories told by a diversity
of characters but given the infuriating
lack of diversity for the industry's
most prestigious awards films should all
take up non-traditional casting so it
becomes the norm and not the exception
[Music]
so Rachel this is a very interesting one
I was at the oliviers where Noma who
played her my only name JK Rowling's
Harry Potter theatrical stage pieces won
the Olivier Award for that role of
course you'll remember she was facing
criticism that Hermione was white and
honest Joe Rowling had to wade in and
say she hadn't cast her my only in the
books as having any particular
background and I got to know Noma after
she won the awards and I was
particularly proud that she because I
think she did a great job there is
another perspective on this which I'd
like to just quote one particular line
from O'Meara Newton which you may have
come across and he said that his view
and he's a black man 39 years old actor
and he says that colorblind casting it's
a strong view he has I just want to read
one line - he says it's the theatrical
equivalent of ignorantly telling your
black friend I don't see color I mention
that only because I want to acknowledge
there's another perspective on this
though III think that you know I think
it depends for me it depends on the
story and you mentioned this in your
introduction the story you're telling is
also an important element here so
whether you go down this route or not
for example if it is a story about say
the South during the Civil War you may
not want to cast a black man treading on
the foot of on the neck of slaves for
example whatever because there may
actually do an injustice to the actual
historic testimony so it does depend on
the story and actually probably more
important for story is real and true and
historic let you represent it accurately
right I mean there is nuance there I
think that I just just see your point
a lot of I spoke to a lot of actors of
color and lots of them said that they
didn't particularly like this phase
Caliban casting and preferred things
like color conscious or non traditional
so that's the first thing but the other
thing is that all of them who I spoke to
talked about hitting a glass ceiling
that just comes from not being cast for
the array of roles that are available to
other people to people who are white
actors who just have more pick and
that's been incredibly hindering so it
just means we never see the capacity
just a very tricky job I know I was one
of just Amazon I recently went to see
just mercy which is a tear inducing film
my wife was actually I think she won't
mind me saying was in tears it's about
the death sentence in America as an
example in that for me what you wouldn't
want is that is that is is that reverse
the races in that there's a
disproportionate number of black men on
death row and that's what the film was
about and it was a black lawyer so that
I think depending on the story can I can
ask you a question I mean devta tell I
love and he can make any role come to
life eternally and I have no qualms with
him as an actor but do you think when
Dickens wrote the character of David
Copperfield he wrote he wrote it for a
man with brown skin or a man whose
wife's good how do you think I think
that's a really interesting question
it's something that say yes or never
because the same thing I want to say
after that I don't think I don't might
my answers are never yes no you should
know that by now Harold she said in
response to this was Dickens wrote it
for his time and the people that parrots
the characters in it are all this time
you knew she wanted to make it of our
time and the sense of relief that I feel
when I watch when I watch David
Copperfield is that looks like us that
masseur my world is that I'm a
contemporary and a famous retro modern
audience a Dickens character
politicizes representation if he's
politicizing dickens he's working up
this film and I actually suspect his
reason for doing but would just taking
on your logic in which case why would
you think if if a film like 12 years the
slave hadn't already been cast and um
what would you think if white people
were cast in 12 years of slave what
particular character attributes of
Charles Dickens mean that he cannot be
played by someone from South Asia
what do use character traits because
Dickens in that time he wasn't writing
about people of color what character but
no but what makes it if you have a
classical story where it is it is clear
the character would have a white set I
think modern-day roles are entirely
different that can be played by by any
color brown skins black skin white sands
whatever just a the couple that have to
be white yeah well because the Charles
Dickens would have written but is it
relevant to the story but I just think
you listen to this imagine just quoted
this this actor Maureen he just he says
this is wrong to do this he is a black
accent he thinks that's wrong his words
were I mean I expressed there's not want
to make it abundantly clear I want
nothing more than see diversity on every
stage in the world I just don't want to
see it for the sake of it is you know
I'm taking points from every one of this
side really and can James Bond be played
by a black garnet yes absolutely
couldn't the black eye play Henry the
eighth probably not because that's wrong
it all comes to the history in the
context and I know what you're saying
but if Dickens was around now the
characters that he would be portraying
would have a far broader range of colors
anyway so we must adapt something like
I'm with Rachel we adapt something and
we look at it through today so a couple
things and one like as we're saying in
the case of Hermione I think that could
be played by somebody of any race but if
it's obviously 12 years a slave just
mercy even then obviously the race is
specific to that story yeah
one thing I would say is in this may
seem out of place this case of
you're called Ruby Williams a black girl
who was sent home repeatedly from school
for having hair that was quote too big
now obviously black hair tends to grow
up whereas Caucasian hair tends to grow
down so for me personally I thought that
was a very racist decision to send her
home on that basis now if the leader of
the country or if it was common that the
stars of films were black women with big
hair big afros that would never have
happened
it would be the norm representation is
key to changing so again he says it's
absurd and distracting when you you
blind I want to bring in Armando
Iannucci and see what he has to say
about that decision
are you already sick of the questions
about cold line casting well yeah I mean
I I can see it as as something that
we'll all talk about in advance of the
film but once people have seen the film
no one will you know it'll be natural
and it'll the question will be asked
because you'll just you'll just respect
them for their for their ability you
know I want to just wanted to choose
actors who were the most suited for that
part so one of the things it's not the
only way of fixing this issue it is one
way but the other thing of course is
that you need a spectrum of stories so
you know what often happens and this is
what actors of color of told me is that
you know let's say you're Lebanese or
Iraqi there was a point when the only
roles that you would do audition for
would be like suicide bombers and
terrorists but if you had scripts that
were written where you know you could be
the protagonist in a rom-com or a drama
or a thriller then it would be
completely different so it's about
scripting as much as it is about casting